oi gente sido bom
hoje eu quero convidar vocês para
conversar sobre um tema que é misterioso
mágico e se chama inspiração pra isso eu
queria convidar vocês uma jornada meio
perigosa na cabeça de um artista sabem
que o artista na cabeça de um artista é
o lugar onde as coisas malucas e imagens
podem acontecer
então por isso espera poder é
compartilhar com vocês um pouco do que
acontece em nosso processo criativo que
é o antes de saber se aquilo que está
criando vai virar uma obra de arte ou
não a gente sempre vê as coisas prontas
a gente nunca sabe o que acontece antes
eu acho que essa experiência que já
escolhas que são muito importantes podem
ser úteis para todos nós que não são
artistas também então aperte os cintos e
abram suas mentes
vamos lá porque a inspiração a os anjos
abrir um céu me falaram as musas me
inspiraram a foi um momento mágico
sem inspiração e todas essas coisas a
gente que a artista gente experimenta
isso com mais freqüência do que a
maioria das pessoas o que é um
privilégio
porém é na verdade o que acontece
a gente se depara com o material ou uma
idéia um tema musical porventura tantã e
aí bom é como a energia para fazer fluir
de uma maneira diferente no nosso corpo
o que acontece é o seguinte a gente vê
que a gente reconhece aquele elemento
está fora da gente normalmente uma coisa
vital o nosso coração se enche de
expectativa a energia passa a fluir
diferente dentro da gente o corpo sente
uma certa relação relação e tudo a gente
age como se uma grande coisa tivesse
acontecido tudo menos a nossa mente é
novamente olha pra que ele fala assim
tantã do que está falando
e aí vem a pergunta é se acha que só os
artistas sem inspiração não na verdade
toda vez que uma criança é vamos pôr uma
criança entrou em abril pela primeira
vez um tubo de ensaio ela sente uma
coisa mágica e sua inspiração
uma menina que abre o livro pela
primeira vez e ver hieróglifos egípcios
e acha que o fascinante até inspirada
será que a nova york uma arqueóloga
na verdade a inspiração não é
invencionismo a inspiração é um
reconhecimento é quando uma coisa que
está fora da gente uma coisa que está
dentro da gente se reconhecem e torna
possível uma grande realização
às vezes a gente nem sabia do que se
tratava aquilo porque nem tudo que a
gente tem medo da gente é conhecido mas
de alguma maneira nosso corpo nossa
mente nossa imaginação reconhecem é é
como se fosse contra a parte de uma
mesma coisa e essa coisa que é
desconhecido até então passa a ter a
possibilidade de se manifestar no mundo
e esse reconhecimento ele passa
totalmente reto pela pelo nosso lado
racional
isso gera um certo incômodo porque o
nosso lado racional adoro está no
controle
e quando ele não está no controle e acha
que tem alguma coisa de errada ea
inspiração uma coisa que não é
controlada pelo nosso lado racional e
ela vem de um lugar que a gente não
entende
aí a minha pergunta é será que a gente
deveria ouvir a nossa inspiração será
que ela é segura
vamos descobrir isso porque esse passo a
passo que vem depois da expiração são as
escolhas a gente vai ignorar esse
momento de reconhecimento ou se a gente
vai seguir ele vê para onde nos leva
agora então na prática lhe propuseram
fazer uma obra a obra é uma obra de arte
o artista que deveria expressar o que
aconteceria se as pessoas na hora de
decidir qual é a missão de vida dela se
conectassem com aquilo que existe de
mais profundo no coração delas na
verdade profunda do seu ser e todas elas
fizessem isso ea gente têm juntas e
colocassem isso no mundo trabalhando em
conjunto
então eu falei assim essa proposta muito
legal me inspirou e achei ótimo né
eu tinha uma idéia do que eu queria
fazer com isso ea ideia mas sim uma uma
imagem que eu pensei que poderia ser
interessante traduzir por exemplo essa
imagem está mostrando agora pra vocês
foi uma referência que eu peguei só que
isso eu queria fazer como o sentido que
estava traduzido nesse conceito que me
passaram
então só que eu sei que a inspiração na
verdade ela não é uma coisa que eu eu
queria uma coisa autónoma ela acontece
dentro de nós e ela vem de uma parte de
nós mesmos que eu vou chamar de o
artista dentro do artista é ele que cria
as coisas que são é maravilhosa a ele
que tem a energia para fazer grandes
transformações
sei que então a gente tem que conversar
com ele muito educadamente então falei
que essa é uma palestra meio maluca eu
virei pro meu artista dentro do norte
dentro de mim mesmo e falei assim que
você acha dessa idéia e acha que é uma
boa idéia que você pensa desse assunto
das pessoas se conectarem com aquilo que
é verdade dentro delas e que trabalharem
juntos e botar isso no mundo
e aí eu fui dormir porque como eu disse
não é nossa razão que trabalha é esse
lado artístico no meio da noite bom de
uma super inspiração acordei super
inspirado com todos os sintomas a
energia fluindo diferente e esse é um
passo importante a gente tem que saber
quando a gente está inspirada é uma
coisa que a gente tem que aprender a
reconhecer e reconhecer que estava
inspirada aí eu fiz essa grande obra de
arte que vocês vão ver vamos ver agora
não é pra mim gente tudo isso essa obra
maravilhosa eu fiz assim estava muito
inspirada
e aí na minha razão olhou pra que ele
falou assim paula pelo amor de deus sabe
desenhar que que é isso de coração zinho
ainda é isso que conseguiu que a sua
inspiração
aí vem o momento da escolha a gente
escuta nossa inspiração ou não no caso a
minha mente racional achei horrível e aí
ela começou a apresentar várias
propostas alternativas de coisas que eu
poderia criar que ela estava inventando
agora não vai passar vergonha se você me
seguir aí eu seguir ela porque eu estava
inseguro com essa idéia
só que tudo que eu fazia não tinha
energia nenhuma era como se esse meu
lado criativo de um atentado em coma
e aí eu falei o seguinte bom quando a
gente está criando alguma coisa não tem
energia envolvida você não sente conexão
com aquilo que é um péssimo sinal é um
sinal de que está no lugar errado
eu sabia disse então eu voltei pro meu
aplicativo faz assim me desculpe estou
desconfiando de você certamente depois
dessa inspiração mas eu vou te dar um
crédito então eu resolvi usar outra
estratégia e se eu usasse a minha mente
a favor da medida e não contra
só fazendo críticas então eu olhei e
comecei a perceber o seguinte os
corações estavam conectados a essa que é
a primeira coisa que falo de itália e
ele estavam se movendo a partir de um
certo e chupava dentro deles eles não
estavam aleatoriamente espalhados no
papel
então existe um eixo que estava presente
ele estava se movendo em direção sempre
visível e quando eles faziam isso eles
formavam um círculo
o circo eu sei porque estou de geometria
é um símbolo de ordem a partir da qual
todas as coisas podem emergir
eu falei assim bom coração tá ligado à
idéia de que as pessoas estão agindo a
partir do coração o centro do coração
está dizendo
falando sobre o núcleo do nosso coração
de onde nossa vontade vem e eles são
orientados então entrelaçados agindo em
conjunto de alguma maneira alguma coisa
pode emergir daí porque esse é um lugar
onde todas as coisas a imagem é o
círculo
então eu falei bom tudo bem não gostei
do desempenho mas eu vou dar um crédito
para a idéia e aí eu comecei a usar mais
o meu conhecimento eu falei vamos passar
pelo estreito
aí eu cheguei nessa forma não foi assim
dessa forma bonita melhor do que estava
antes a um pouco menos mal eu continuar
investindo em energia nisso já que
aconteceu em seguida foi eu passei tudo
isso por um software que chama maia é um
software de três de lá é minha intenção
era mudar os materiais e começar a
colocar todos os objetos entre dimensão
dourado fazer isso ficar mais bonito né
e aí eu fiz isso em contato com todos os
meus coraçõezinhos selecionados a limpo
no programa mas foi assim ainda está
faltando alguma coisa aí eu virei pro
meu lado que eu tive foi assim eu não to
entendendo o que está faltando mas eu
acho que está faltando alguma coisa
nesse momento esbarrei no controle e
todos os corações se moveram o que vocês
vão ver agora é o seguinte o que estava
faltando era eles entrarem em ação
quando em quando eles entraram em ação
juntos uma coisa mágica aconteceu o que
vocês vão ver agora é o que acontece
quando todos os corações se movem a
partir do seu eixo profundo entram em
ação juntos e isso não podem tratar do
rio gente é só o processo mesmo aquilo
que eu vi na tela do meu computador e eu
queria que vocês prestarem atenção na
música porque a música também tem uma
história
o que acontece quando os corações se
movem a partir do seu próprio eixo
é uma experiência de ordem é uma
experiência de sentido ao gerar harmonia
todas as formas eram harmonia não tem
uma forma que quando se movendo assim
não gere harmonia não gerem beleza e
esta descoberta quis seguir a intuição
seguir a minha inspiração e proporcionou
é como se todas as coisas fluírem a
partir desse lugar mais profundo dentro
da gente e a inspiração na verdade ela é
o que acontece quando a gente se conecta
com esse lugar que esse lugar de conexão
do fundo do nosso coração
da música que eu fiz começar essa
animação foi na verdade um vídeo pra ela
é o que aconteceu foi que estava
compondo uma outra música que era uma
pessoa que eu tinha que entregar estava
super no prazo
e aí de repente é eu tive uma inspiração
é minha inspiração foi aquele claro caso
o verbo foi inspirada só que eu estava
fazendo a minha inspiração não tinha
nada a ver com o que eu tinha que
produzir naquele momento eu estava
atrasada
então eu virei pro meu lado que eu tive
foi assim você não vai entendendo
querido estou super ocupado agora não dá
tempo de fazer outra coisa que não é
aquilo que eu tenho que fazer e aí eu
ignorei ele e continuei tentando
trabalhar na minha no meu trabalho
oficial
e aí ele o lado criativo entrou em coma
de novo nada do que eu fazia dava certo
tudo ficava esquisitas que eu estava
dando super errado
falei tá bom então eu vou te ouvir de
novo vou fazer o que estava pedindo
porque assim eu consigo focar depois
daquilo que eu preciso e aí eu escrevi a
música é mais ou menos uns 15 minutos
novamente uma os 40 minutos demorou pra
fazer aquele pedacinho de música
relaxei deixei um negócio de lado e vou
tentar passar original que tinha que
criar criei deu tudo certo e entreguei
quando estava preparando a apresentação
aqui é eu quis mostrar essa animação e
só está faltando uma música que juntar
essas duas músicas que essa música que
estava no fundo da minha tela parada e
colocar junto com animação e ver o que
acontecia
o que aconteceu ela estava perfeitamente
sincronizadas
ela tinha a mesma duração exatamente a
mesma duração e todos os movimentos que
a música fazia eram feitas por expor as
suas formas e aí eu falei assim nossa
que coisa mágica é como é que é possível
então gente é isso
pra quem não tá querendo quem a gente
acha que precisa ser racional não tem
razão nenhuma
mas pra quem não está convencido ainda
se alguma coisa bonita não é bonita é
uma questão de bom gosto
quando eu vou produzir isso aqui é o meu
objetivo era produzir uma obra de arte
então o que eu poderia fazer parte disso
que fosse uma obra de arte
eu mandei imprimir essas cada segundo
dessa animação pode gerar uma escultura
que foi impressa em 3d numa
chin acabei de chegar e essa é a
impressão na verdade é um protótipo
porque a partir dela que a gente cria a
peça final
então essa é uma das peças
aí você pode dizer sim a essa bonita
festa avaliar o resultado de alguma
coisa com base na estética é meio
suspeito na gente mas não em metas então
essa prática também tem metas teve uma
ideia original
só que a minha imaginação não me deu só
uma versão disso ela me deu para cada
frame que foi feito é uma forma
diferente
ela me deu 1.176 versões diferentes
daquele princípio que eu tinha pedido e
ela me deu uma música e ela me deu uma
animação e uma música que eu nem sabia
que eu precisava de uma animação que eu
nem sabia que eu ia fazer porque elas
foram feitas de maneira independente
então na verdade eu queria convidar
vocês a viver esse processo porque é que
a gente se colocar à disposição da nossa
inspiração desse lado sabe dentro de nós
que sabe mais do que a gente pode fazer
tanto efeito quando está falando
simplesmente de um processo criativo
para fazer uma escultura um desenho uma
música
imagina o que ele não é capaz de fazer a
gente colocar à disposição o nosso bem a
nossa matéria prima mais preciosa que
aquilo que é a nossa verdadeira natureza
e é esse convite que eu queria fazer pra
vocês muito obrigado